I remember we took some mushrooms one
time to a party in high school because I
grew up in the area where you could just
get much I mean psychedelic mushrooms
grew on everything they grow on your
[ __ ] cousins back if he took a long
enough nap in Louisiana they grew
everywhere they go everywhere cuz
everybody had something [ __ ] in
their yard and then it would rain every
single day for about a half hour right
so it was just I mean you see people
picking them and eating them and
Families out there and join him in the
afternoon I mean it was everybody was so
it was psychedelic heaven so we would
ride out and go get him over one time
getting a trash bag I'm probably bout
thirty five pounds of mushrooms right
and one time a golden retriever came
running at us across this field and we
thought he was pissed cuz we were
tripping and then he got to us we ran
for like a half an hour he got to us
finally we're crawling away from
thinking he's evil and loved us and
licked a mean golden retriever I thought
he was mean for us cuz the hair his hair
was kind of slicked back oh like an evil
golden retriever so no I took that bag
of monsters to that party right and a
bunch of people ate a mood never had him
before and then we played a game of
hide-and-go-seek right I was like no
I'll count you guys go hide right oh no
and I ain't never went to [ __ ] look
for Timothy I've never seen that dude
again
[Music]